can we talk about kyrie irving a little
bit is that
on the list kyrie what up in dribble
they say well i don't know if you want
to bring it up tam but what about kyrie
some say well he just came out and made
a statement saying that he's not against
the vaccine he's against the mandates
and that he also wants to be a voice for
the voiceless and that he's making uh uh
you know that's what he said exactly but
what he's doing is he's making a stand
on this issue there's also a 26 year old
atlanta hawks basketball player named
brandon goodwin who's reporting that
that according to his own personal
experiences it was the vaccine that
ruined his mba career and he's saying
that he got uh blood clots uh fatigue
respiratory conditions he got sick after
the vaccine and he's blaming it on
ending it his ending it his uh
basketball career his professional
sports career well look look luke we
don't know if that's true but but that's
what he should have
this guy claiming he had this experience
clearly it's a dangerous conspiracy
theory you know he's just he
his his theory about these things
happening to himself certainly are are
not correct
no
anecdotal at best so he apparently we
have a story um i i just googled it i
don't know what this source is it's just
his former atlanta hawks guard brandon
goodwin claims covet 19 vaccine ended
his season goodwin left nothing up to
the imagination to his twitch audience
recently this is from uh just about a
week and a half ago uh the only thing i
can really say is
yo like vares exists for a reason the
vaccine adverse event reporting system
exists for a reason and i just want to i
want to stress this point yeah maybe
he's telling the truth but if you're
vaccinating 330 million people and
there's adverse events that being
possible then you're going to get these
stories we got to be careful not to take
volume and ass and and compare it with
like uh proportionality but i don't i
don't know i don't know i'm not going to
be i can only say this i agree the
vaccine minutes are wrong and if you're
getting stories like this and people are
freaking out people got to be told to go
to people they know and trust and be
able to make decisions they for
themselves and if people want to assume
risks in their life that's their choice
for me
i don't smoke i hate smoke i can't stand
people smoking around me
if i go to a bar and people are smoking
i suspect i'll go outside i'll go
somewhere else i'm not gonna be like
everyone here should stop smoking
because i no
well there's definitely an interesting
debate happening right now because you
have a lot of sports commentators
attacking kyrie uh saying that he's you
know an idiot a loser that he's stupid
for doing this but there's also you know
the the tale of of magic johnson who had
hiv and there was a big discussion about
even allowing him to play uh in the nba
and there's people saying he shouldn't
play he's at risk to other players we
should ban him he shouldn't have the
right to play in the nba now i feel like
people are making that argument
especially with this claim with the you
know with kyrie irving who's being
denied
the access to even play sports because
of you know something that some medical
professionals uh estimate that there is
low risk when it comes to professional
athletes from even getting um and
there's also the debate of you know if
all the other players are are vaccinated
well then uh you know wouldn't it work
why did why do we need to have him do it
as well so that's the conversation
that's happening online right now and i
think it's a very interesting one
because it's going back and forth the
trader uh you know stupid guy and people
are saying he's doing the right thing
making a stand here for people who don't
have a voice
so i think it's i think it's a good
decision i support his decision to make
his own personal decision right and
people are talking about the money that
he's giving up but you know it's useful
to consider the money that he's already
made right he's in a position of comfort
because of the work and energy and
effort that he's put in and i don't
begrudge him that whatsoever but he does
have the luxury of having this type of
conscience that most americans do not
have
and uh so that is the kind of person who
could actually uh take a risk and make
make a statement and actually
make something positive happen whereas
you know just a regular guy with a
regular job and regular family if he
doesn't do it and he gets fired that's
not going to have political change kyrie
irving he's in position to do that so i
pulled up brandon goodwin wikipedia it
says goodwin missed the 2021 nba
playoffs due to a respiratory condition
oh
yeah
so uh you know there are other nba
players speaking out against this um
whether you like them or dislike them i
know some people have different mix
feelings about kyrie irving at least
there's a conversation
at least there's a discussion here that
wouldn't have happened i think people
are trying to dismiss this conversation
but i think being open to this
conversation to people's concerns is
something that will help everyone out in
the long run and i think that's why it's
so imperative to to talk through these
issues the irony here sorry shannon
sharp i think was talking very
loudly about how kyrie irving should
just basically shut up and play
uh but at the same time
back in may of last year when people
were protesting because of george floyd
you had people also saying shut up and
play and so uh there were people
criticizing those who said that then who
are now saying shut up and play now it's
very interesting how this issue is uh
actually crossing party lines
it is a bit different i mean the issue
here is like kyrie irving can't play
there is no shut up and play it's him
literally being like hey guys i can't
play because of this well sure but
lebron
the shut up part is take the shot it was
uh right
but there's there's a difference lebron
could have just played the game but he
wanted to be political yeah so i think
it was laura ingram was that shut up and
dribble is that she was the one who said
it well it was shannon sharp i was
talking about making this comparison and
telling kyrie irving to just get the
shot and go play people are depending on
your teammates are depending on you
tyree's playing he's not a mule kai you
can do whatever you want you're the
reason the cavs won the first
championship just kidding that was a
team game
bro and if you're gonna have some time
off so first the team said he can't play
home games if he doesn't get vaccinated
and now they say he can't participate
he's not gonna be able to play at all
with the team so if you've got time on
your hands bro come on here and you know
what's funny is like when the la county
came out with their vacs mandate i
didn't look into the details but one
could assume that performers were
excluded right so i was thinking like
you couldn't go to a lakers game if you
didn't have a vaccine but are they going
to require all the incoming players to
get the vaccine of course not because
performers politicians etc they all have
exemptions from these vaccines well not
with not not in new york city not with
kyrie irving
and and it's really interesting
in new york city even the performers are
required to be back well the players are
the players are yeah this is where
you're kind of performing you know it's
a type of performance
yeah it's it's very weird uh that this
is happening a lot of people are saying
that kyrie should be traded to a team in
florida uh so there's a lot of
discussions about that but there's also
a lot of people just kind of taking
cheap shots at him and even though i
don't kind of agree with his other
previous political positions um you know
it's it's okay and i i think his stand
here is definitely worth noting because
a lot of people in the mainstream media
a lot of people try to dismiss it try to
act like there's this point of view that
doesn't exist it clearly does it's here
and and i think ignoring it only makes
it grow but by addressing it you you
could actually do the right thing here
uh and actually uh be able to
uh you know talk things out in a way
where it leads to less harm more
understanding and it fixes a lot of the
problems that we have in our current
society so i believe there are other nba
players who have come out so that
they're not vaccinated because they have
the antibodies bradley beal i think in
washington
was one of them as well
more people need to speak up man the
antibodies from having the infection are
something that we really need to address
yeah i just i disagree we talked about
quite a bit
it changes the argument from no mandates
to mandates with exceptions i see so
when you know when rand paul comes out
and he's like natural antibodies are
being you know lied about and fouchy
lied i'm like why are you even
discussing it who cares you shouldn't be
demanding people's papers indeed indeed
i agree with that 100 percent but like
is it better to uh just deal with the
vax mandate in 100 capacity uh or have
your binary position or at least also
try to chip away at the binary
if we're standing on the line shocked if
we're standing in the line and the line
is do you accept the mandates or not i
say no and you won't get me to cross
that line and apparently a lot of
southwest pilots feel the same way but
it's also it's worth mentioning that a
vaccine against us is different than
testing to not have it in your system
because there have been evidence that
people that get the vaccine can still
get coveted evidence there's no studies
that just came out harvard's study that
showed that the vaccine correlated with
increased rates of transmission
i treat it all as a harvard i i'm not
considering another stuff proof i get
this news and data and this and that
it's evidence to me but there is
evidence yeah um i tweeted it today i
found it yeah there's there's a lot of
medical studies and and you know it's
also important to note here just like
you know some doctors that we talked
about earlier were censored on instagram
it's also important to note that there
are medical professionals there are
doctors there are studies that if you do
talk about on social media that they do
take away your channel they do take down
videos a lot of doctors a lot of
prominent medical professionals have had
their accounts terminated so there is
this aspect of this as well but there's
you know actual science which should be
debated which should be questioned uh
that's being denied to a lot of people
and you know a lot of people say the
science is settled well the science
seems to be changing a lot i tweeted a
video today on my twitter account on uh
at luke we are change and it's a music
video and it's dr fauci saying 100 safe
and effective 100 safe and effective and
then you have all the media reports 100
regurgitating the same thing and then it
goes to 99 98 97 96 literally all the
way down to some media publications
reporting 33 percent um effective so
there's different media reports there's
a lot of noise there's a lot of
distractions out there but you know we
have to understand here we're in a very
fast moving situation uh that we still
don't know the full long-term
ramifications of i'm gonna i gotta
disagree
it's it looks like an op-ed based on
data not a harvard study made a
conclusion okay
but i don't know for sure i don't know
for sure i found that with a lot of
these studies there's harvard data but i
don't see a study other than just data
charts you know breaking down
from my experience there are some
studies that are are risky to bring up
but if you bring them up and have it's
in the paper the link there's a link is
in the first sentence if you have legit
debate like we can do on the show if
it's you in a room it's hard to like
break through the echo and then you
might you might frame it in a way that's
dangerous but if you let me have a
convergent debate yeah i'm going to read
this headline it says increases in covet
19 are unrelated to levels of
vaccination across 68 countries and 2
947 countries counties in the united
states
i think if you dig in there according to
the article that i look linked to you
man i'm on the spot i'm having to
re-re-examine it it's also important to
note that we are not medical
professionals we are not medical doctors
yeah but no i'm like if there's if
there's a harvard study saying that
there's a correlation i think it's the
opposite actually jack this this this
study um that that was linked to it says
increase in covert are unrelated to
levels of vaccination now that that is
that that specifically literally means
vaccines aren't causing or any way
related to an increase but it does show
that the increase is unrelated to
vaccination which is strange because
there should be a decrease
there's also some
interesting preliminary data when you
look at case cases in singapore iceland
israel and the united kingdom some of
the places that had the highest
vaccination rates uh and when you look
at their case numbers there's a there's
there's a correlation there that is not
an easy one to talk about and we have to
tread lightly here because again uh
you know correlation does not prove
causation but but there is something
going on here that i think we don't
fully understand the quote from the
research says in fact the trend line
suggests a marginally positive
association such that countries with
higher percentage of population fully
vaccinated have higher covid19 cases per
1 million people so one thing that makes
me think is that not that the vaccine is
causing the body to make it happen more
but the people are more confident
because they've been vaccinated so
they're going to public places there's
many factors the symptoms are reduced
the symptoms are your first sign that
you're sick and should self quarantine
if you don't have symptoms then you can
go out
well
it depends because there's also some
places reporting that most of the people
hospitalized are the people who did go
through the procedure so there's our
again uh there are some preliminary
reports uh you guys got to do your own
research you got to talk to your medical
professionals you got to make up your
own mind we're not telling you guys what
to do here uh we're not the medical
professionals we're not the medical
doctors but there is a lot of outlining
data out there that we have to kind of
talk about in a roundabout way because
it's a landmine sometimes um and it's
important not to jump to conclusions
it's important not to just you know go
off one thing and say this is 100 the
truth because honestly i don't think a
lot of people know exactly what's
happening here uh and to say you're
definitively understanding this i think
is disingenuous the least thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you